hello everyone I just got back from the
gym and today was the first day I
managed to run 10 minutes at a pretty
fast pace without my heart about to
explode and that's a pretty big success
for me since I haven't really done any
physical exercise for like five years
you know combined with a sitting job
it's really it really took a toll on my
body and you know I feel pretty hyped
running without your heart almost
exploding is very awesome so you know if
any of you are in a similar situation
you know don't even think twice about it
just you know go and do something all
right
that being said I just wanted to share
that with you guys here it is I've never
had so many requests for one game like
all of you who've seen my other videos
alpha zero versus talked Fisher demanded
a game where alpha zero has the black
pieces and that first one I saw this
game I didn't really enjoy it but okay
now that you really requested it this
much I decided to give it another look
and okay I did find reasons to show it
so here it is stock Fisher has the white
pieces in this game and it opens with
efore we had e5 Knight to f3 knight c6
and Bishop to b5 the Royal opus and
Knight to f6 alpha zero goes for the
Berlin defense I guess I guess Kramnik
was right choosing this in his World
Championship match against Garry
Kasparov b3 and Bishop to c5 and this is
the same variation Fabiano Caruana used
the two days ago to defeat Carrick and
in London chess classic and here Bishop
captures and c6 was played by stockfish
kirkin in this position continue with
Knight c3 and then castles and only then
captured on c6 obviously stockfish
considers this to be better but
stockfish didn't have access to his
opening repertoire so it might be just
something he caught it calculated D
captures on c6 and now castles by
stockfish Knight to d7 we have Knight B
to d2 officer o castles and Queen to e1
f6 now and forcing that Aoife
one night the c4 and rook to f7 and I
want you to keep a very good very close
eye on this rook this rook will really
go places this game
8:4 and here alpha zero plays Bishop to
f8 not allowing c3 and Bishop to b4 or D
for which tempo and also making room for
the night on the c5 square King to H 1
and now Knight comes to c5 a 5 we have
Knight the e6 and night C captures on e5
already a very interesting move this is
move 13 stock Fischer decides to give up
a piece for two central pawns and okay
this this might be considered enough
compensation but you'll see what happens
it's quite the drama of course alpha
zero accepts the sacrifice F captures
only five nine captures on e5 and this
comes with an attack on the rook and in
this position alpha zero plays rook to
f6 and stockfish replies with Knight to
g4 it attacks the rook alpha zero plays
rook back to f7 and stockfish repeats
Knight to e5 again would attempt on the
rook and it's interesting here alpha
zero obviously can play rock back to f6
again and it will be a row by threefold
repetition but in this position alpha
zero refuses to draw offer and place
rook to e7 and this really makes you
wonder why did after this first Knight
captures on e5 why didn't alpha zero
immediately play rook to e7 why did it
play rook to f6 first was it just
checking if stockfish will find the
right continuation or was it bluffing
maybe you know it's hard to tell I mean
obviously there is a very nice
explanation to this but you never know
either way Knight to g4 rook to f7 and
now Knight to e5 and here alpha zero
declines the draw please rook to e7 and
again keep an eye on that rook we have a
six now a six is a great move by
stockfish well to my comprehension as it
were as it destroys the
bone structure black has on the
queenside and you can't will be five
because of night capture cc6 this you're
now getting back your material and white
will be better here so after a six c5
now we have F 4 and now Queen to e8 a
character son b7 Bishop character son b7
and Queen to a5 attacking the c5 pawn we
have 9th to d4 and Queen to c3 now not
allowing the knight to infiltrate the
position with a knife characters on c2
rook to e6 and Bishop to e3 rub the b6
now again keep an eye on that rook
Knight to c4 attacking the rook and rook
to be four now and this is move 23 and
already this this rook made seven moves
and I'm not including the castle castle
castle is a king's move so seven moves
already I moved 23 with the rook and
again it makes you wonder about that
principle of not using the same piece
twice B 3 a 5 now rook captures on a 5
rock actress on a 5 and Knight captures
on a 5 so alpha 0 gives up a pawn and
plays Bishop to a 6 now Bishop character
son d4 rook captures on d4 and now
Knight to c4 rook to d8 and this rook is
really on a mission to visit every
square on the board
g3 we have h6 and Queen to h5 and this
comes with an attack on the bishop and
on the c7 pawn but alpha 0 doesn't mind
alpha 0 is happy to give up another pawn
for activity it plays Bishop to c8 going
for this nice h3 square Queen captures
on c7 and the bishop to h3 rook to g1
and now Rob to the 7 attacking the Queen
and here stockfish plays Queen to e5
offering a trade of Queens and alpha 0
accepts this Queen captures Knight
captures and rook to a7 and it's very
interesting would you would you accept
the Queen trade here you're still up
that piece
and black as black has four points for
white has four points for that piece so
four points for a piece that that
certainly does sound like compensation
so would you would you accept the Queen
trade in this position alpha zero thinks
yes Queen captures Knight captures with
the tempo and rook and rook to a7 and
while white does have four pawns for the
piece alpha zero will use the bishop
pair like like a god Knights the c4 now
we have g5 now trying to break up that
structure rook to see one Bishop to g7
Knights 3 5 root 2a 8a Knight to f3
Bishop to b2 now rook to b1 and the
bishop to see 3/9 to g1 Bishop to d7 and
now Knight to e2 attacking the bishop
bishop to d2 rook to d1 attacking the
bishop Bishop to e3 King to g2 and the
Bishop to g4 now pinning the night and
it's interesting so far you know from
the moment they entered the endgame a
starfish wasn't able to move a single
pawn so he still he still wasn't able to
use that you know which is his advantage
rook to e1 and now Bishop to d2 again
would attempt on the rook rook to f1 and
now rook to a 2 now rook has infiltrated
the second rank and this is game over h3
now Bishop captures rook to f2 now both
bishops are attacked and now not just
giving up a bishop but also grabbing a
pawn or while they were at it
Bishop captures on f4 rook captures
Bishop on e2 and now Bishop to e5 and
now already white only has 3 points for
the bishop and it's not looking good for
white rook to F - knocking - g7 g 4
Bishop to d4 rook to e2 this rook has to
keep an eye on the C to pawn if the C to
pawn falls it's it's game over
King F 6 e 5 check Bishop captures now
King to f3
giving up a pawn to get
again some King activity rook to a one
rook to F to rook to e1 now King G to
check Bishop f4 c3 now rook the c1 I'm
going after the pawns now that the C
pawn has moved d4 rook captures on c3d
captures on c5 rook captures on c5 now
already by a White has only one be a
pawn for the piece B for her up to C 3 H
for simply king e5 h captures H captures
rook to e2 check King to f6 King to f2
Bishop to e5 and after rook to a - group
to c4 now attacking both both of these
pawns rock a6 check King e 7r okay five
attacking the bishop King defense
rookies X check bishop defense and in
this position stockfish resigned at the
game it's going to lose one of these
pawns and then he will only be down a
piece and it's pretty you know
resistance is futile as as the board
would say so yeah that's the game alpha
zero with the black pieces and I'm very
interested what do you think about how
it played with the black pieces and I'm
I'm very interested what do you think
about that rook to f6 maneuvered them
back to f7 then rook the rook to e7 why
did it play rook to f6 first was it just
kind of testing stockfish it if it will
find the right continuation or you know
maybe it just calculated that rook to e7
was a path to victory and is it is it
program you know to strive for victory
or did it just learn that it should
strive for victory instead of accepting
a draw with the black pieces it's a it's
a very interesting you know what
happened there so yeah I do hope you
enjoyed it I would like to thank even
your ovoid salvador Acosta Daryl Morey
and their Radley for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot - really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here I will make both
of them about alpha 0 vs stockfish thank
you all for watching and I will see you
soon and one more thing I just
check my YouTube analytics yesterday and
I saw that all the traffic on my channel
75 75 percent of viewers on my channel
are aren't subscribed to my channel so
75 percent of views come from people who
are not subscribed so if this is a you
know if this is your choice
you know that's fine but maybe maybe you
if you simply forgot to subscribe or you
know you never thought about it then you
know it will really help me you know
figure out how many subscribers I'm
currently dealing with and you know
consider subscribing I never I never
really mentioned this in my videos so
I'll just mention it now and maybe in a
couple of months after this so yeah once
again thank you for watching and I will
see you soon